hey you guys
movie retrospective time
so today the movie that won pretty
overwhelmingly in the poll was the 1994
adaptation of frankenstein mary
shelley's frankenstein to be precise so
i don't know if people voted because i
do put like what year it is especially
if it's something like frankenstein
that's had like a million adaptations so
i don't know if you guys knew that this
was the one that we were gonna be
talking about or if you were hoping that
we were going to talk about the boris
karloff one i don't really know but this
one won uh i saw it come up on hbo max
and i was like oh i haven't seen that
since it came out like i saw in the
theater
and i remembered it being okay but i
didn't really remember all that much
about it so i was kind of like
interested to revisit it and had you
seen it or no yeah i had seen it but i i
guess i didn't like it and and there was
a lot of the stuff that i didn't uh
remember so
probably what it was is that um 94
i was in the army and they were probably
playing it and i caught a bit of it you
know on vhs and i was like nah
you know they'll like it you know they
stopped watching it um
but seen it again last night it was good
it's real good
i liked it now the thing about it though
it's like way
way way more over the top than i
remembered uh as far as very very stagey
acting and like really just kind of like
some of it even like veers over into
camp but that's kind of okay because i
kind of feel like that's what makes it
entertaining it's supposed to be almost
like a period piece i guess it's it's
almost like operatic yeah you know what
i mean
yeah kinda i know
what i think it was trying to do is
trying to be kind of like um
uh remember um
the dracula that had come out what was
that 93 92 92
it was trying to be like that where it
was
supposed to feel i think a little bit
like an old movie but it was all brand
new with color and everything you know
but the acting was kind of like
old movie from the 30s
yeah so that's kind of like the spirit
in which i took it because i know like
i've watched other people because this
very famously like when it came out like
it made its money back but it got like a
lot of criticism even back in the 90s
for being just like way over the top and
for being because uh kenneth branagh who
plays victor frankenstein and he
directed it as well
uh you can tell that he's like a
complete raging ego maniac on this
because he's pretty much like every
single scene of creation i want to be
like shirtless and like showing my pecs
and like covered with liquid and stuff
like that and he's just like switching
around all the way
well because the thing about kenneth
branagh is that and the reason that he
ended up directing this because i don't
know if you knew but this was the same
uh production company it's francis ford
coppola's uh production company
because they had done dracula and
because it had been so successful
they're like okay well next we're gonna
do a frankenstein they were gonna do all
of them if that fits then it's what i
thought it was yeah they were gonna do
all of them i think the reason that
dracula probably worked better other
than you know keanu and winona being
kind of like miscast a little bit yeah
was because
the francis ford coppola's dracula was
very stylized in the way that it looked
like visually so you could tell that it
wasn't necessarily trying to be like
realistic or anything i kind of felt
like this one
maybe it was it was supposed to be like
that yeah well it i think it was but i
think it might come off that way yeah i
think if it had been more stylized it
probably would have come across better
probably right yeah um and also i will
say that i think one and i do like this
movie i do but i can understand like
criticisms of it where they just said it
was just like wildly over the top like
he could have like reigned it in some
and i do agree with that i think another
thing that kind of like let it down a
little bit is that robert de niro as the
creature in this he's never given a name
like as the monster
he's so good and so subtle
that everyone else like shrieking and
like sw and like sweeping around and all
these like
crazy camera movements and stuff like
the the juxtaposition is a little bit
gives you a little bit of whiplash too
well i think i think they're trying to
give him some bunch of gravitas like
he's the only sane [ __ ] in the
movie yeah everyone else is just like a
screaming loon
and he is he is he's he's he's kind of
the best character he's the best part of
in a weird way you know he did kill the
kid and he did [ __ ] frame the other
woman i mean he did
do some evil things but he was kind of
kind of rationalizing it like you know
well i'm not a human being you made me
daddy doesn't love me he threw me away
and know this and that
and then the people are all trying to
kill me and you know and and uh you know
you do what i say or something or
something bad you need to pay for your
sin
against god for making me you know
and um
yeah when when the creature gets into it
when he starts talking or the movie the
movie really picks up if you ask me it's
good when he start
starts playing his role in it
i think it should have happened earlier
but they're trying to make it like the
book and it's supposed
based on what you said that this is
supposed to be one of the more one of
the more faithful adaptations of the
book it is they did change some things
uh which maybe we'll get into that a
little bit but um overall because you
know honestly like most people know like
the boris carla frankenstein and stuff
like that was
not it you know obviously it was kind of
loosely based on the novel but
a lot of the adaptations like leave
things out like
i'm not sure because i think there is a
movie called frankenstein
unbound which i think was maybe the same
universe as dracula untold which i
actually really liked i haven't heard
much good about frankenstein and bound
but i haven't seen it so i can't really
say i think that one is a little bit
faithful to the book too but so maybe
that has it too but this is the only
frankenstein adaptation that i've seen
and i'm sure there's other ones and
people will tell me what they are that
actually has the framing device
of the arctic exposit expedition because
if you guys haven't read the novel it's
been a very long time since i've read it
i've read it in school
and i think i read it one time in my 20s
but the whole thing
the whole novel is actually told as a
flashback is told as like a story like
this ship this guy is like trying to
find uh what's he trying to find like a
like a not the northwest pet in north
but northwest passage but it's like
something through the [ __ ] arctic
circle or whatever like he's so he's up
there on his the terror expedition or
whatever and um they find
the monster well then they find dr
frankenstein like chasing the monster
and dr frankenstein like while he's
dying
um tells them this whole story you know
what i mean and then the captain is
writing all of the whole story which is
a novel length in case you didn't know
like to his sister
so
so that's the footage yeah it's like a
found footage which like i said very
very popular
epistolary style well dracula is
completely like letters and journal
entries and uh you know german which is
when i was a kid when i was real a
voracious reader you know when i was
younger that [ __ ] was so tedious i
didn't like the that kind of stuff with
the exception of [ __ ]
lovecraft i liked lovecraft but he was a
more updated version of that
this [ __ ] was usually tedious to read
if it's done well i like it
but
a lot of times it's not done well yeah a
lot of times that's a whole lot of
nothing nothing really happens in the
book it's
it's just you know i mean
i haven't read this one but usually in
this style like the dracula book when
you read it nothing really happens
nothing's in [ __ ]
nothing's in well because nothing's just
in regular yeah like everything is like
oh and then this you're reading reports
about something about something that
happened right and i know why they did
that because like i said that was a very
popular like literary trope back then
because it gave the story like oh my god
the [ __ ] really happened you know what i
mean it gave it to it's like newspaper
articles so like you said it's like the
same as the appeal of found footage um
it was just written so i get why they
did that but the thing about and dracula
excuse me and and the creature reads
that reads a book like that also in the
book so there's the book in the book
the creature is reading yeah i think
frankenstein's [ __ ]
uh yeah uh what's his journal and that's
how he finds out who he is and how he
came about so it's kind of funny they
got found footage in the final footage
movie so meta yeah it's better and i
don't think like i said i haven't it's
been probably 20 years since i've read
the book i've remembered like some
things in here being different this is
pretty accurate
um but they did change up some things
like uh especially toward the end like
having to do with like the creation of
the bride and stuff but i don't remember
because it's kind of a minor detail but
i don't remember in the book if that's
how the monster found dr frankenstein
again like through his journal maybe it
was but i can't really i don't remember
i don't actually remember how he ended
up finding him again but it's like i
said that's kind of like a small detail
it's probably why i don't remember it
but yeah so i had seen this in the
theater and remember like i was like i
was okay or whatever i said oh it's like
really close to the book which i thought
was kind of cool because we hadn't
really seen that like in 1994 i was like
wow they even had like the the arctic
expedition and they did a lot of the
um of the monster like being able to
talk and like learning how to read and
like being more of like philosophical
and but yeah i agree that like when de
niro shows up like the movie like has
elevated several yeah you know things
because prior to that
well i guess he's kind of like um
like a calming influence because this is
a very i'm not gonna go like say this is
like a full-on like baz luhrmann kind of
like phantasmagoria freak show or
anything where everybody's like running
around and singing and waving their arms
and everything but it's kind of in that
direction you know what i'm saying well
dr mary shelley
you would think you know when you when
you let's see the hell and bottom carter
[ __ ] character in there you think
that's probably how [ __ ] shelley was
you know and the way
the way she probably wrote her character
is you know kind of slightly over the
top and hysterical but people were like
that back then
yeah they were just like well even much
to do so you had the you know even dr
frankenstein i think in the original
book it's like every time he saw like
the horror of what he had done he'd like
pass out he had to be passed out
he was a constantly [ __ ] yeah
all the time uh they were they were
wilting playing people well probably but
the you know the the health was bad too
yeah because of like the conditions late
1700s like in the early 1800s you know
people were rich people were drama
queens man
yeah the young rich people were drunk so
if you're coming at it from that point
of view but i was okay well the thing
about it was that francis ford coppola
was initially supposed to direct this
one too
but then i guess he was like [ __ ] it i
don't really feel like it because
well he was more into dracula like
dracula was his passion project he
wanted to do a frankenstein but then
he's like i don't know if i'm as
passionate about frankenstein as i am
about dracula he didn't really have a
vision for it so they decided to go with
kenneth branagh now kenneth branagh who
at this point like this was 1994 he's
generally known for being in shakespeare
adaptations which most of which are very
good like henry v and he did like a
whole bunch of them
and he had also been
do you guys remember that movie dead
again i think he did it with his wife at
the time emma thompson and i remember
that being good other than the end being
ridiculous but i haven't seen it in a
long time that's another one i kind of
have to rewatch because i think i saw
that in the theater too but so he was
like a very very well respected
uh shakespearean style
actor and director so they gave him this
and i feel like
you know well i it might have been okay
if he was just like directing it but the
fact that he was the star of it too
i think it was just too much for him to
resist you know what i'm saying like
running like running around with no
shirt all the time i liked it i did too
i did too
i'm just saying that you have to go into
it like expecting that it's gonna be
like super over the top yeah i think i
think i think he called it in terms of
tone but i also agree that had it been a
little more visual
you know visually distorted kind of like
the original dracula was they were
stylist stylistically and everything
you'd know that you're not we're not
talking about the real universe we're
talking about
a fanciful universe written by a
basically a teenage girl back in a long
time ago that's although i will say of
all the classic
monster like original novels it's a good
one i think frankenstein is probably the
best written yeah although you could
make a case for um
jekyll and hyde although that's a
novella it's like pretty short but i
think frankenstein is the best written
one she thought about it in my opinion
she thought about it you know i mean
what would happen if you created this
person would it would consider you its
father wouldn't it and then people would
reject it and then what would it feel
and you know so she she i mean she
essentially even with you invented
science fiction right it's good yeah how
would you get the electricity this as he
does see in the old original movie you
know he [ __ ] sends him up through the
roof a lightning bolt hits him but in
this no it's done with electric eels
which yeah totally fair i mean i liked
that kind of like variation it was a
little bit weird like i that he had this
massive like bag of electric eels just
like up on his roof all the time and
then he was stealing amniotic fluid from
women when their water broke and
getting all kinds of you know so it's
biotech man [ __ ] biotech yeah and it
was also mixed with like
magic and alchemy some of that was
involved he was it was it was
it was technology but uh dr frankenstein
was studying like old you know arcane
lore and stuff from alchemists so it was
a mixture of everything yeah so it's
like when he went to originally went to
the university in ingolstadt um he kind
of wanted to be like hey these like
hundreds of years old
books like you know paracelsus and
everything like that he's like can't we
do this that and the other he wanted to
go like a more philosophical or like you
said alchemical route with it whereas
his uh you know instructors and stuff
are like man we don't do that [ __ ]
anymore it's like we do our own stupid
[ __ ] but it's like we don't do that
stupid [ __ ] anymore you me
bring on the leeches mary called it
though it was yeah
uh it was bio electrical and chemical
and biochemical and well and and it had
you know genes were involved but she
didn't know anything about genes or dna
back then but yeah even darwin did fluid
amniotic fluid put a [ __ ] in a
damn
kettle pressurizing and she's pressure
it was pressurized like this okay he put
him in a crock pot like a big truck
and it had electric eels come in you
know what i mean and there's parts of
them are grounded and there's a [ __ ]
positive and negative and then the eels
[ __ ] come in and shock the [ __ ] out
of them and it wakes him up and
and there he goes like wow i was
sleeping because he was in a womb he was
in a fake womb yeah that's essentially
what it's doing i mean it looks it looks
kind of like a sarcophagus it was like a
big sarcophagus it was a sarcophagus
slash uh instant body he to me what it
looked like and then it had a big
respirator on the top [ __ ] breathing
oxygen into him so if you ask me he made
a mechanical womb
and then shot yeah i guess that yeah
that's that's what it was supposed to be
that's what it was with me yeah but uh
fun fact though i don't know if a lot of
people are big enough to give birth to
an adult that's i guess that was the
lungs above it yeah yeah yeah i guess
that's what it was yeah
yeah how cool would it be if somebody
did like a purely i'm sure somebody's
probably done this somewhere but um like
a purely
bio-organic kind of like frankenstein
where they actually like built
like a big giant
like a like a david cronenbergian kind
of like [ __ ] flesh i just think it's
i think it's amazing that just some rich
teenage girl in the 1700s could [ __ ]
just kind of
dream up of
how would you makes bring something
alive
artificially well so the thing about it
though is that kind of close maybe we
can't do well the thing about it though
is that in the novel that's just what i
was going to say is that you know how
like most of the movie adaptations have
lightning right so everybody kind of
assumes that that's what happened in the
book in the book
she doesn't really specify like how he
gets brought to life it's kind of like
she kind of implies that it was like
no she doesn't imply that it was
lightning she implies that there's
alchemical stuff she just says something
about like dark processes and things
like that so she just leaves it real
vague okay so the movie actually is
filling in the gaps of what she said
yeah i mean the thing about it is that i
think why uh so many movie adaptations
you know immediately go to lightning one
because it makes sense and two because
one of the things that gave mary shelley
the idea for the book in the first place
was galvanism yeah shock shocking like
shocking the dead frogs and stuff like
that that was one of the things so i
don't think she put that in the book
exactly
but it was either implied or so i think
that that's kind of why like a lot of
people picked up on the lightning but
this is the first one that i've seen
that doesn't have actual lightning when
they were doing that that was a cultural
sensation everybody would know that you
could shock these frogs and these dead
bodies and they'd move yeah they had a
guy in italy that was put on whole shows
you know well yeah that's what well
that's where she got the idea from
because they were all talking about it
so i would think that if you read this
book when it was new you would know what
it was she was talking about yeah and
they even in this movie they make
reference to it too because he's kind of
like doing the frog and yeah and all
this other kind of stuff but yeah so
this
okay so this hues like pretty close like
i said they have the whole like framing
story of the arctic where you know they
find dr frankenstein and he's like i'm
up here chasing the monster the monster
kills all the dogs which again makes
them a little less sympathetic but okay
um you know uh and so then he's like hey
i gotta tell you this like crazy [ __ ]
story listen to this [ __ ] uh the
captain's played by aiden quinn by the
way um he's only in this for probably
the dude
is in it yeah well i had forgotten tom
hulse plays uh henry cherval who is you
know a doctor frankenstein's friend like
at university yeah and he's in the same
class
i was calling him amadeus
the whole time i was like look he's best
friend so there's wolves
yeah there he is but yeah it's uh he's
actually really good in this and even
though he's an american actor and like
most of the other ones are brits it's
like he doesn't like he didn't stand out
he doesn't really stand out like i don't
think he's not necessarily like trying
to do a british accent he kind of is but
it's not like real jarring you know what
i mean
natural to me yeah that's it it just
seems like his natural voice it's not
super weird it doesn't it doesn't stick
out like i said like whenever it sounded
like it was transatlantic more than
anything that's kind of what i was
thinking that's probably what he went
with yeah i think it was just a it was
an american accent an old an archaic
american accent i like that he provided
a lot of like comic relief like not
super zany but i like that he just kind
of was very sardonic and like kind of
like said funny [ __ ] yeah and helena
bottom carter plays this is star studded
you guys i've forgotten helena bonham
carter plays elizabeth uh you know
frankenstein's sister slash love
interest she she's not he's not she's
not his real sister
she's like she's essentially well she's
like an orphan
because her parents died of scarlet
fever and like i said i think that
happened in the book too um i don't know
if they were like a distant relative or
something but it wasn't that weird like
it didn't strike me as that weird like
in the book like they didn't see it as
weird so you know um
dad is ash the robot yeah ian holm i was
gonna say he's in this too yeah he's
also great uh john cleese is in it yeah
uh with some fake uh teeth yeah
and he plays a serious role he's not
being funny he's great though i really
like him and honestly he i think he
should have been in a little bit more
because he was really good in it but
he's basically like one of
frankenstein's professors yeah he's like
one of his mentors he's like the one
that is at the school and he's like oh i
dabbled in some of this [ __ ] and you
shouldn't do it he created he created a
life form and destroyed it but he
wouldn't talk much about it said it's
horrible yeah and he's like you should
totally not do it frankenstein's like oh
i'll gotta do it i i gotta do it
frankenstein's [ __ ]
buddy
uh
it's not his it's not his uh professor
it's one of the professors yeah at the
at the university who was listening to
listening to frankenstein's comments
he's going oh he's on he he knows what
he's talking about and he's talking he
wants to bring back the dead i did that
that's what he's thinking he's like
[ __ ] i bet then he got him in on the
secret like yeah he had a whole handbook
and everything things that he did that
worked
and um
so frankenstein actually didn't come up
with it all on his own
his buddy did it before him
so
yeah so it's not like frankenstein did
it on his own it's just that evidently
his
frankenstein approved on the
process is isn't that right well
yeah he said basically a guy made some
mistakes yeah he said he was so close
because that guy like john cleese ends
up getting killed yeah like not too long
after he gets ends up getting stabbed
and um so he dies and so
frankenstein is like woohoo i'm just
going to go in there like steal all this
[ __ ] that's right he created a living
thing but in the notes it says it didn't
work it was not funny like it was all
[ __ ] up it was all [ __ ] up with
birth defects and it did and it what do
you say what was the word he used non
non-functional and nobody said it was
not fun something like that yeah
or he said i can't remember like the
word he used exactly monstrous or
something i don't know if that was one
of the words yeah but he said it like it
didn't really work out and then then he
was just like bro what the [ __ ] am i
even doing and then like he's like let's
not do that again right i mean probably
he should have destroyed the notes if he
was that like
you know if he felt that strongly about
it but because as soon as he dies
because he like dies in the next scene
like he gets stabbed and then
frankenstein's like woohoo and sleep
just pilfers his [ __ ] notes and so
like he goes through the [ __ ] and then
he's like oh he was so close like he was
just one i don't think that that john
cleese had hit on the amniotic fluid
thing
so that was his kind of improvement so
he's like woo this is going to work
and i mean it does work but not quite
now i don't think this might be a change
from the book too
because i think in the book
frankenstein just like dug up you know
whatever like murderers they hung that
day which does happen in this because he
actually takes the body well most of the
body of the dude that stabbed john
cleese
but he pops john cleese's brain into it
yeah
now does that happen in the book i don't
know i don't think so it wasn't a
criminal mind didn't it
yeah
it's a smart guy a smart guy right yeah
and then like he took i think he took a
couple other pieces like he took a leg
here and there because everybody there's
a cholera epidemic like going on during
this which like i said that was from the
book too so i like that they kind of
added that in
but i don't remember if he actually like
took that professor's
brain and like popped it into
like a criminal's body essentially they
do kind of go into
he popped it into the body of the guy
who killed him
yeah and i'd be like if
like if i woke up it's like if somebody
murdered me and you put my brain into
like the murderers but i'd be like dude
that's [ __ ] up what are you even doing
why would you do that he didn't mean to
kill him but he stabbed him
yeah so so yeah fight over them
vaccine was it a collar collar it was
cholera yeah he didn't want to take it
yeah so then he's like well i'm just
going to stab the doctor and then i'll
die
not of cholera but i'll just get i'll
get hanged instead yeah better i guess
good
job i panicked i guess he was panicking
i was like yeah he only he only had one
leg anyway he had to give him another
leg that's right that's why he had to go
cut off so he's like hey where's the
collar where's all the dead bodies from
calling ooh this looks like a nice leg
i'll just be taking this one home by but
you know that's like kind of yeah but uh
so yeah i don't think that's from the
book but that kind of works out though
because i guess it kind of just keeps it
less random now let's talk about two
here's another kind of big change from
the book
in the book and please correct me
because like i said it's been a while
since i've read it
in the book
um
the monster comes back to him and
basically says i'm gonna [ __ ] up all
your [ __ ] like i'm gonna kill all your
family unless you make me a bride
because you know at this point the
monsters he's all like [ __ ] up looking
and he's been like you know uh attacked
everybody just thinks he's like scary
and everything like that so he's like
well i need one person that's like me
um you know and we can go off together
and we won't bother anybody ever again
so the doctor says okay yeah i'll do
that
but in the book i don't think he either
never makes her
or he makes her and then before he wakes
her up he's like what the [ __ ] am i
doing and destroys her you know what i
mean i think that's what happens in the
book i don't think he ever makes her and
she wakes up and everything like that
what they did in the movie though and
it's like i kind of think this was an
okay
decision i mean i guess if you're gonna
go in this go this way because it does
it did like raise the stakes some
because i don't remember
who he got like to reanimate for the
bride in the book but like i said i
don't think he ever reanimated her in
the book
what he does with this one
is that
he um he's like okay well i'll make you
a bride and the creature brings him
justine who is the girl
that he had framed for killing his
little brother william the he's like
five or six or so yeah it's gonna seem
very convoluted if you haven't seen this
movie yeah well i mean the story of
frankenstein is so it's kind of
everybody everybody kind of knows it
knows each other and they kill each
other and then they end up inside the
damn same monster with somebody else
like frankenstein's body
was the dude who killed a brilliant
scientist it was used to go inside that
[ __ ] body
and that guy also made another
frankenstein before that frankenstein
yeah so there's a lot of
it's like a russian nesting doll it's
kind of like reanimation
kind of like really well yeah i mean
rihanna's the same kind of thing was
happening your girlfriend died so we had
to reanimate her and put her in this one
and this one comes and then then another
reanimated guy tries to have sex with
the new reanimated girlfriend and you
know the reanimator series is crazy like
that too
well yeah and i do kind of feel like
well yeah i mean there's a reason why
this story is like resonated for so long
but yeah so what they did
so the monster brings him the body of
justine because justine who was their um
it was their housekeeper's daughter yeah
and like a friend of the family she was
like a friend of the family and um
the monster kills william who is
frankenstein's little little brother
who's like many many years younger he's
about six yeah he's like six years old
so the monster kills him justine is out
looking for the kid because they don't
know he's dead yet they're like looking
for where he went to and then she falls
asleep in a barn for some reason right
reason and the monster comes out late
yeah they said she was tired yeah
the monster comes and essentially like
leaves a locket that the little boy had
had and leaves it on her so like frames
her for the little boy's murder so then
they take justine into
custody
a big mob comes pulls her out the jail
and like takes her up on the roof puts a
rope around and just like [ __ ] throws
her off the roof man it's like a pretty
horrifying she falls like four stories
before the [ __ ] rope gets tight and
normally would have pulled her head off
i would think i used to do that because
in real life it probably pulled her head
off can i just say there was a great
moment i can't remember the name of the
woman that plays justine because she's
not like i mean she's in it but it's not
like a huge character
but the moment that they put that rope
around her neck and she realizes what's
about to happen what a great moment of
acting that was she looked [ __ ]
terrified yeah and i was like and i was
like ooh i okay that was good like that
whole reaction that she had was like so
[ __ ] great lynch mob got her yeah it
was like horrible and that was how
that's that was how the creature was
getting getting um revenge for what the
what had been done to him because uh
basically a lynch mob was after him too
yeah because and they and like he comes
into town like looking for bread or
something they're like hey what the [ __ ]
why are you stealing bread and then his
hood comes off and they see us all
[ __ ] up like a face and they said oh
you're the guy that's causing all the
cholera yeah because that's of course
another great touch is that
is that she was just he was hiding
uh in the courthouse
and the lawyers were going like no this
is illegal this is illegal the lynch mob
took him anyway
took her anyway took her anyway yeah so
they tried to [ __ ] protect her but it
wasn't any good
yeah it was like a thousand people i
mean that was a scary i thought that was
like a pretty scary like an effective
scene yeah that they did because i was
like whoa okay that's like that's yeah
visually all the sets and everything
that looked pretty authentic the
costumes are real good they look period
uh the movie looks a lot better than i
remembered it it looks it looks good
like yeah on par with like amadeus or
something yeah yeah but the yeah so the
monster brings justine's body and
frankenstein is like no he's like i'm
not and the monster is like yeah but you
just said like all these bodies are just
what they call them raw materials like
so it shouldn't matter like that you
knew this girl and he's just like man
i'm not doing it and he's like you you
better do it or i'm gonna like [ __ ] up
all your family he's like no i'm not
gonna do it so he's gonna see me on your
wedding night yeah so he and that's from
the book that's actually right from the
book um that quote that he says so he's
like yeah well if you don't do it then
uh i'll be with you on your wedding day
like if you won't give me a wedding
night i'll be with you on yours or
something like that yeah so that's like
right from the book and uh vic and
frankenstein who's kind of like a
dumbass he doesn't understand i don't
think the implications of that he just
think that he just thinks that the
monster wants to kill him even though
he's already killed his brother well no
he says
he says so if you're going to kill me
you know you're going to kill me and he
goes no kill basically
the creature says killing you is the
easy way out you know basically he's
like that he goes what i'm gonna no he
says that would be easy on you yeah
killing you because he's gonna make it
worse than that which he's threatening
everybody knows
yeah which he does in the book also yeah
um yeah so he uh he's already killed his
kid the kid he frames justine who also
gets killed
and then uh you know frankenstein's like
no i'm not gonna you know make you a
bride so of course he gets mad and he
goes in there and straight up like he
marries elizabeth
uh and she they're they're they haven't
even like had sex yet they've never
consummated the marriage it's like the
wedding night and they're just like
woohoo finally like after all because
they've known each other since they were
kids
uh and so
but then like somebody's like oh we saw
the monster outside so he's like hold
that thought i'll be right back and then
the monster ends up in the room and
strida pulls her [ __ ] heart right out
of her chest up yeah he's strong he's
real strong
pop just pulls it right out yeah
and then blade not only that but it's
like as if that wasn't undignified
enough he then like just knocks her body
off the bed and it felt falls into a
lamp and like her head catches on fire
it burns all her hair and it burns all
of her hair off and big patches and [ __ ]
yeah so then frankenstein and this did
not happen in the book frankenstein says
oh well i can bring her back to life and
i'm just like bro have you not learned
anything like through this whole
interview did you watch reanimate did
you watch her didn't you watch
frankenhooker this is the same thing
that happened to frankenhooker okay yeah
so he basically he's like well
uh i you know i want to keep her head
but her body's kind of like uh [ __ ] up
because she doesn't have a heart so he's
like oh well coincidentally like
conveniently justine's body's still
laying here so i'll just pop elizabeth's
head off and put it onto justine's body
yeah um see he just kind of mesh mashed
them together and then he like brings
her back
and she's uh not super happy about it no
and then the creature sees her and he
goes that's mine that's mine she's mine
and and then they they get into the
[ __ ] tug of war
i totally thought her arms were gonna
pull off like sally from nightmare
before christmas the bride's trying to
choose which one she goes wants to go
with and she actually chose the creature
uh but then
at the end dr
victor [ __ ]
gets her to look at him and then she
[ __ ] glitches out and grabs a dab oil
well she looks she looks at the
creature's face and then she's like oh
[ __ ] that's what my face looks like too
because her face she looks really
[ __ ] grabs
because by the time this was all
happening the creature was looking
better than he did the stitchiest [ __ ]
[ __ ] got pulled out he was he was
healing up so that was a nice touch i
liked that yeah he started to he started
to look just like you know robert de
niro yeah with a scar on his face so you
know he wasn't ugly really he was
[ __ ] intimidating looking spooky
looking but i wouldn't say it was ugly
not you know as bad as once it started
to heal
up yeah and then um
she glitched out and [ __ ] grabbed a
oil lamp and held it over her head
crushed it and all the [ __ ] burning
oil went she [ __ ] it was a great
stunt it was it it was not cg
it was a woman and what looked like a
bridal gown running at full speed
through the [ __ ] hallways setting the
damn internals of the castle on fire
and she jumps out the window she died
but it was a it was a good stunt it was
a
whoever that was was fully on fire
it looked real
yeah it looked like a woman's build
you know well yeah they got women's
stuff man they do fire stunts so yeah i
mean or or it was
it might it could have been a dude i'm
not really sure but i was i wasn't
really looking at it look like [ __ ]
helen carter running on fire
i think how they did the close-up
of when she first broke the lamp i think
that that was like the head and stuff
like that i think was a dummy but then
they superimposed her face over it
somehow like because they did have some
digital effects in the 90s they just
weren't really all that great yeah but
the the running part where she was
running on fire yeah that was real that
was just somebody like an actual sun
person yeah but it looked like a
body wise that looked like her in the in
a wedding ground
she jumped off the top of the staircase
she fell probably two three stories huh
yeah open
there are big open spaces inside the
houses the living room the entranceway
was like you know
like an aircraft hangar in there that
the house is big
i mean it's i mean victor the whole
thing was that he's like well i don't
want to make justine into a monster
because i know her but then like as soon
as his wife dies he's like oh okay never
mind i'll just you know pop this
girlfriend's head and i'll just like bri
i'm gonna like
he's he's just fully like lost his
[ __ ] body at this point so victor
frankenstein loses everything man he
loses his [ __ ] family loses his house
[ __ ] everything burnt down on the
ground so he starts [ __ ] chasing
frankenstein to the [ __ ] because his
dad dies in there too yeah i don't think
the monster i don't know if the monster
killed him or if he just died of yeah
yeah that wasn't wrong
yeah it looked like he just died and
like maybe died of a heart attack from
seeing him yeah and seeing the seeing
the creature but um he chases the
creature up to the north pole that's
when they run to the dam they run into
the damn expedition that's up there
it's pretty cool because
the guy the captain of the ship that's
hearing this whole story but when he
does finally see uh
uh
the creature he's kind of got respect
for the creature
at one time towards the end after victor
frankenstein dies
he asked the creature to to join the
crew yeah he's like come with me come on
come with us you know he's down in the
water and he's holding the damn
torch and he's going no i'm through with
man i'm through with man yeah he's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] he goes out to a damn
iceberg
where he's got victor frankenstein's
body on a damn pie or pyre ready to go
and he sets him and victor frankenstein
on fire and sets himself on fire he's
out there on an iceberg burning
i think that's how the book ends too
yeah i'm pretty sure that's like yeah he
gives his own life he says [ __ ] he takes
his own life he's like i'm done with
this [ __ ]
well like it goes down like a g all
proud [ __ ] standing everybody's
burning up
he's like i didn't ask to be here yeah i
know i like [ __ ] some [ __ ] up and kind
of like a viking funeral it was yeah
yeah kind of like a viking funeral
but yankee funeral and what happened to
[ __ ] darth vader at the end
of fire strikes back or [ __ ] gear
return to the gym well that's the thing
is like frankenstein is such an iconic
novel that even things that aren't
related to frankenstein have used like
things from that too
you know what i mean yeah because it's
just like penetrated the the cultural so
much but like i said i'm gonna have to
see frankenstein and bound because i
heard that one was like kind of similar
to the book too although i heard that
the movie wasn't very good
but i liked dracula and told i did too
yeah i like says i don't know if it's
the same director
but um but i'm not sure i have to look
it up but yeah i mean if you want to see
uh a very uh you know there are some
changes obviously uh you know that we've
kind of got into but
this is the probably the most accurate
to the book of any frankenstein movie
i've seen i'm sure there are some that i
haven't seen that are maybe more
accurate i heard there was another one
that was like made for tv that was
actually pretty good and pretty accurate
to the book i forgot to mention that
actually
not the first draft of the script that
was written by somebody named um steph
lady but the second version of the
script was actually written for this
movie was actually written by frank
darabont um and he did not like this
movie at all uh he was like well he said
the quote was something like and i'm
paraphrasing but he says something like
i think it was the best script i ever
wrote and the worst movie that i ever
saw like based on a script that i ever
wrote well he's like because he's like
how i had it on the page he's like i
tried to make it as close to the book as
possible and he's like the book is
actually pretty subtle
um he's like so everything that you see
like this wildly like over-the-top kind
of like operatic type of stuff he's like
that's not in the book and that wasn't
in my script
he's like that was kenneth branagh's
thing it's not over the top by today's
standards
i think i think it's more over the top
by today's standards i don't know i
didn't really find it all that unusual i
thought the tone was about kind of like
the old kind of like
bram stoker's dracula with with it's
about like that i i there wasn't a big
difference
i'd have to watch them both back to back
i thought it was enjoyable i thought it
was enjoyable i did too i didn't say
that
i just said that i had forgotten that it
was like more over the top than i
remember i was trying to be very
theatrical and classical yeah and and
big everything's big you know but and
you know it worked i think
uh you know had the sets been
a little more stylized
i don't know it's hard to say that's
hard to say yeah because i think the
dracula one was more
that worked because like i said it
looked more theatrical because it was
more
uh
you know stylized it didn't look
realistic yeah it's not supposed to be
very realistic this one it looks
realistic
it looks pretty realistic but it then
like it's kind of like it's acting is
staging right yeah
until de niro gets in there right i mean
because he's very i think they're trying
to say that he's the only real person
yeah like the meaning of the restrained
the meaning of
the meaning of the story is [ __ ] y'all
y'all suck and y'all don't know what's
cool
attract them
uh [ __ ] the creature knew what was cool
that you know
there was some philosophy involved
well the whole point of the story was
that you you shouldn't uh step on god's
don't step on god's dick
um don't judge things don't judge people
for how they look that's you that's
another one y'all are a bunch of
superficial [ __ ] out of control
lich bob's killing people right in front
of right in front of the damn court
systems that you ignore you know it's
just stuff like that you know y'all are
the monsters not me
that's the that's yeah that's that's i
mean he did monster monster did monsters
things too but i think that i mean mary
shelley was kind of like trying to say
it it's almost like danny that was like
he was like your child he was like your
creation you brought him into this world
like he didn't ask to be here yeah and
you didn't teach him anything you
brought him here and then you abandoned
him yeah right right i think in the book
it was more clear that he abandoned the
monster like [ __ ] that that didn't work
bye it was kind of like that whereas in
the movie
he thought that the monster had died of
cholera or he assumed that the monster
had died of cholera and like a dumbass
he didn't check yeah probably should
have checked on that
but he didn't
the monster was uh left on his own and
was trying to survive out in the wild
and was trying to make friends and
it sometimes would make friends only the
blind man wanted to be his friend and
and even though the blind man knew he
was
he knew that he was uh his face was
[ __ ] up
and just in a split second some people
chased him off hitting him with a stick
you know because they thought he was
attacking the old man yeah uh it's just
you know he killed their landlord for
him he killed the lady and brought in
all of their crops yeah and did i did a
bunch of work for him yeah the landlord
was beating people and [ __ ] throwing
the kid around and [ __ ] yeah i mean no
one was sad to see yeah
you know so he kind of had it coming so
but uh yeah frankenstein was like uh the
the frankenstein monster the creature
was a good-hearted creature
and he was intelligent and people kept
[ __ ] him over and that turned him
frustrated him and
says well if you don't if you know it
was kind of like eye for an eye well if
you're gonna [ __ ] me over my [ __ ] you
over yeah and if no one will react to me
with love and compassion then i'm just
gonna like [ __ ] rage out which like i
said that's you know that's it's a very
it's a very universal yeah it's a it's
like a human theme you know and the
thing about it is that even though he
did monstrous things
victor was the real monster because he
didn't take responsibility
for one he's for stepping on god's dick
and like going all like hubers and
everything yeah but also like then he
made it
and then he didn't yeah so he just like
unleashed it on the world's like well i
washed my hands of that you know what i
mean the creature considered him his
father yeah you know what i mean he
didn't raise it yeah so
it's a morality tale you know you it is
true it is drama you know you can tell a
teenage girl wrote it but a very
intelligent teenage girl and it makes
sense and it's the the story holds up
it's it's in that old-fashioned foul
footage
motif you know what i mean style which i
hate reading i hate reading that [ __ ]
although the frankenstein one isn't
really that bad because pretty much
there's just like the the beginning and
the end yeah you know with that but and
then the rest of it is just like reads
pretty regular didn't do what the
regular drag what real dragon what
dracula dracula was entirely like that
was like all journal entries and stuff
and you know i think she wrote this on
it on a basically kind of like a
challenge i think like a day it was like
a dare type of deal they were saying
they had to come up with some kind of a
ghost story
for was it christmas what was there no
they were deadline or something no there
wasn't um they were just all we did a
show about it yeah it happened it was
her and lord byron and percy shelley and
uh john polidori
they were all
kind of like well they were all into
like kind of enlightenment kind of like
free love and all that kind of stuff um
but yeah they were all
trapped in their uh villa like on one
summer because it was you know the year
without a summer it was just like two
weeks of torrential rains and they
couldn't leave they couldn't do stuff
outside so they kind of like were
trapped inside reading ghost stories i
don't know what that is it was a volcano
went off yeah and it 1816. blackened
disguise and it [ __ ] up like couple of
years worth of weather um
i think it
it was really one harvest season i think
it was
it was yeah one or two i mean 1816 that
summer was the worst one like they had
like crazy [ __ ] weather yeah um like
a lot of the crops didn't fail yeah a
lot of the crops failed because it never
got warm enough like in certain parts of
the world and stuff like that yeah but
yeah did did they know what it was i
don't think mary shelley at the time i
don't think so i think maybe like a
little bit later but i could be wrong
about that but that was the sky was red
for several days i think
right after that when it
like uh the sky was red yeah for like a
week two weeks yeah
it was then the weather went crazy it
was a big deal it was a big explosion if
it were to happen today people would
think that was the end of the world
and back then they were just like wow
that's some weird that's some weird [ __ ]
this weather is quite annoying
guess we got to stay in here and write
some of the most classic things ever
well and the other thing too is that and
i think we brought this up on the show
where we talked about mary shelley and
that um john polidori was there too and
he actually wrote uh the penny dreadful
the vampire with the y uh which is maybe
one of the inspirations for
uh dracula okay although they think that
maybe he ripped the idea off from lord
byron because lord byron wrote something
about a vampire too but yeah so this was
like way before dracula came out because
dracula was like toward the end of the
19th century frankenstein came out in
1818 yeah so yeah it's much much older
so there's that and like i said mary
shelley kind of like invented science
fiction pretty much
uh basically yeah so because this was
kind of the first story that had been
like that at least like the first one
was like a big sensation but yeah so um
this movie is actually on hbo max if you
haven't seen it um you know give it a
watch and see because i haven't seen it
like probably since it's in the theater
like i said it was a lot more over the
top than i remember but it's still like
really enjoyable and it's still
pretty accurate to the book they did
change some things around but it's it
follows the beats of the novel like
pretty closely which is uh pretty
admirable and it's really kind of like
all star i love the makeup they did on
de niro i really liked uh daenerys thing
the set design the costumes the score is
nice too i i really like that a lot but
yeah i mean it's totally worth watching
and i think now
remember when we did the the um movie
that had michelle pfeiffer and uh jack
nicholson in it that was called wolf
yeah
i don't remember if that was the wolfman
installment of this cycle
or if the wolf man with benicio del toro
was
i don't know and i really want to watch
that again too because i remember seeing
that in the theater also and like well i
like benicio del toro in anything but i
remember that being pretty good but i
don't really remember anything about it
but then i was just kind of like well
wait i don't i don't remember like what
cycle that was part of because i they've
tried to like do all of these like
universal monster reboots like multiple
times why don't they do creature from
the black lagoon though
hmm i don't know i really like that one
but anyway yeah so this is on hbo max uh
check it out if you've seen it or if you
haven't seen it a long time let us know
what you think about it in the comments
and that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys on the
next one
bye
you